The answer is, of course, all of the above.
All of these would be good ways to test a GUI application
because a GUI interface, similar to an operating system interface,
usually represents a trust boundary.
And what I mean here is just the fact that it's usually the case
that the GUI can't rely on a user to always present valid inputs.
Therefore, a GUI application needs to be ready for basically anything.
And it turns out that when my children were younger,
one of them was really good at crashing Windows machines.
You would just set him down at a Windows machine,
and he could make it unusable within a couple of minutes of just pounding on the keyboard.